- We're just beginning the
investigation into what gave rise
to the January 6th
attack on the US Capitol.
But what we're learning
is that this was no fluke.
This was planned in
advance from everywhere
from Instagram to
Facebook, to the dark web.
And this wasn't just idle chatter
from some rando on a
conspiracy theory forum though.
They certainly participated as well.
No, a lot of these people
were middle-class Americans
who just contracted brain worms
from Newsmax, OAN, Fox News
and sometimes even their
relatives on Facebook.
And while it's certainly possible
that some of these people
never thought that it would
get out of hand the way it did
a lot of these people
planned it ahead of time.
And what unifies all of
these people together
is that they are all going to face
incredibly harsh criminal sentences
for some of the things
that they perpetrated
whether they intended to do it or not.
And while some of the perpetrators
flew in on a private jet
and are now asking for
a presidential pardon,
let's talk about what
crimes all of these rioters
and their leaders might be charged with.
Hey, legal Eagles.
It's time to think like
a criminal defense lawyer
because a lot of these
rioters are going to need one.
Now, before I dive into
the litany of crimes
that these writers might face
there are two general considerations
that I think are particularly
interesting here.
The first is that a lot of
people have been surprised
at the relatively light charges
that have been levied so far.
So far hundreds have been charged
and probably hundreds more
will be charged as well.
But people have been surprised
at the types of crimes
that they've been charged with,
many face lesser charges,
such as unlawful entry,
disorderly conduct and
defacing public property,
and only a few have been accused
of the more serious crimes
like felony violations of the right act.
And we're gonna talk about
that in just a second.
But one thing that is overlooked here is
that these might not be the final charges.
It's pretty common for
authorities to make arrest based
on readily proven charges in
this case such as trespassing.
And then weeks later prosecutors can seek
a grand jury indictment
on more serious charges.
And a lot of this has to do with the way
that federal courts operate
because in order to charge
someone with a felony,
you have to go before a grand jury,
a grand jury although it
has a very grand title is
really just a group of individuals
that act as a check on
prosecutorial power.
Even before things go to trial,
generally speaking a district attorney,
or in this case a US
attorney would have to go
before a grand jury and say,
here's the probable cause
for me to indict a criminal.
And only after the grand jury signs off
on that particular proceeding
can you then indict someone
for a felony charge?
One way around that is
a US attorney can swear
an affidavit of probable
cause to a magistrate judge
and get what's called a criminal complaint
to start the proceedings
and avoid having to convene a grand jury.
You basically start the
process by complaint
and you can get a complaint
for either a misdemeanor
charge or a felony.
But the difference is that,
while you can charge a misdemeanor
without ever going to a grand
jury, generally for a felony
you have to go in front of a grand jury
within 30 days of getting
that criminal complaint.
Now, there are two main
reasons why you might wanna use
the complaint process and might
explain some of the things
that we're seeing with
respect to the rioters.
The first is that some jurisdictions don't
actually have a grand
jury convened right now
because of COVID related reasons.
And the other is that you
might use a criminal complaint
to get someone into the court system
to get them under the court supervision
so that you can go back
and charge more serious things later.
So with the initial charges filed
the federal prosecutor might
go before a grand jury later
and then seek significantly
more serious crimes.
And even then once there
is a formal indictment
you can always convene a grand jury
to get a superseding indictment
and charge them with
even more serious crimes.
So if you are a Capitol rioter
and you think you're
off relatively scot-free
because you were just charged
with misdemeanor trespass
more serious charges may
definitely be on the way.
Now, the other issue that
I think is overarching here
is the issue of conspiracy,
because a lot of these people
coordinated with each other
both before they attacked and
laid siege to the Capitol.
And then even while they
were in the midst of it
certain people coordinate with each other.
There is truly a federal
conspiracy statute
but for the most part
that's an add on to other
and different crimes.
People have to agree to some sort of crime
and there has to be a meeting of the minds
but you can't conspire to
do something not illegal.
You can't conspire
with your friends to go
have dinner together.
That's not a crime, I
guess unless you're talking
about COVID risks, but
let's put that aside.
You cannot conspire to do
something that's not a crime
but the benefit of charging
someone with conspiracy
from a federal prosecutor's
perspective is that,
you don't actually have to
complete the crime to be guilty.
You just have to take one overt act
in furtherance of that conspiracy
or in furtherance of that
ultimate criminal end.
So if there are
circumstances that give rise
to an agreement, a meeting of the mind
where people take at
least one step toward it,
then effectively all of the
people who are participating
in the conspiracy can
face penalties that are
basically the same as the
initial underlying crime itself.
So we're just about to talk
about all the different crimes
that all these people
might have committed.
But on top of that, if
any particular person
regardless of what individual crimes
they might've committed themselves,
if they agreed to participate
in a conspiracy to commit
one of these crimes
they could be guilty of
that conspiracy as well.
But with that understanding,
let's dive into the actual
crimes that the Capitol rioters
might be facing.
Now, of course, there were
a lot of people there doing
a lot of a legal things.
So not everyone is
likely to have committed
one of these crimes, but
this is sort of a smattering
of the things that they're likely to face.
And the first is the word,
that you've probably been hearing
a lot these days and that is sedition
in particular a seditious conspiracy found
in 18 U.S.C. section 2384
which states that if two
or more persons conspired
to overthrow, put down
or destroy by force the
government of the United States
or to levy war against them,
or to oppose by force
the authority thereof
or by force to prevent hinder
or delay the execution of any
law or by force to seize take
or possess any property
of the United States.
Now we have covered the law of sedition
and treason many times on this channel.
And at this point, you're
probably sick of hearing me talk
about how it's not sedition.
It's never a sedition that
these people are guilty of.
Well, congratulations, because
this is not the same case.
This is probably a slam dunk
for many of the rioters.
They probably committed sedition
because lots and lots of people stormed
the Capitol clearly used force.
Specifically they tried
to prevent Congress
from certifying the election
and certifying that Joe Biden is
the president of the United States.
If that's not using force to oppose
a law of the United States,
I'm not sure I know what it is.
So despite the fact that
it's never a sedition
here it's probably sedition.
And by the way, because
the events of January were
so excited credibly preposterous
that's the legal term.
I've noticed a ton of new
people coming to the channel
but only a small number
are actually subscribed.
So if you enjoy this legal analysis,
and I wanna see me lose my
mind over the next thing
I'll have to explain as a
lawyer, make sure you subscribe,
but there's actually an interesting Coda
to this whole sedition conspiracy thing
which is that in September of 2020,
the DOJ created a memo
which actually recommended
charging protesters with section 2384.
The only thing is that
those protestors were
the BLM protestors over the summer.
The memo was authorized
by former attorney
general Bill Barr signed
by now acting attorney
general Jeffrey Rosen.
And they intended it to be used
against black lives matter
protesters and Tifa.
And the memo goes on to
recommend charging protesters
with violations of 18 U.S.C.
1361 damage to federal property
18 U.S.C. 844 use of fire or explosives
18 U.S.C. 231a civil disorder,
18 U.S.C. 2101 a riots.
18 U.S.C. 875 interstate communications
18 U.S.C. 1369 damage
to veteran's monuments
and 18 U.S.C. 1952
interstate foreign travel
or transport patient in aid
of racketeering enterprises.
And no, I am not going to
cover Rico in this video
but this memo is a
really interesting lesson
that all of these things
that are on the books
can be charged in circumstances
that you may or may not agree with.
And while a lot of people
want to throw the book
at the Capitol rioters,
perhaps they might not feel as strongly
about throwing the book at the protestors
over the summer who supported BLM.
So that takes us to the other buzzword
that you've probably been hearing a lot.
And that is insurrection.
Now that's covered in
18 U.S.C. 2383 rebellion
or insurrection and section
2383 makes rebellion
against the United States a crime,
specifically whoever
insights sets on foot assists
or engages in any
rebellion or insurrection
against the authority of the United States
or the laws thereof
or gives aid or comfort
there too shall be fined
under this title or imprisoned.
Not more than 10 years or
both end shall be incapable
of holding office under the United States.
As I've covered before,
there are a whole bunch
of other criminal laws
that apply here that are
probably a better fit than rebellion.
This sort of rebellion insurrection.
We might be splitting hairs.
They're not necessarily trying
to overthrow the government.
They're just trying to
change the government
from their perspective.
So arguably I don't think this fits
unless they did something really stupid
like claiming it was a revolution.
- [Interview] Why did you wanna go in?
- We're storming the Capitol.
It's a revolution
- Come on.
But arguably the same arguments
apply to 18 U.S.C. 2385
which is advocating the
overthrow of the government
though a lot of people did
some incredibly stupid things
that might actually toe
the line on these ones.
For example, the infamous racist known
as Baked Alaska whose
real name is Tim Gionet,
live streamed himself breaking
into the Capitol building
and called for all the
Congress members to be hung
in the middle of the riot.
So who knows at this point,
it depends on how aggressive
the federal prosecutors want to be
and how determined they
are to get a conviction
in these different cases.
But that takes us
to another really
interesting federal statute
which is the anti-riot
act in 18 U.S.C. 2101.
Now the anti-riot act requires
that a defendant travel
in interstate commerce
or use its facilities
with the intent to follow
one of the objectives
listed in one through four
each with a riot as the objective.
Now, if this crime sounds familiar,
it's probably because
this was the central law
at issue in the trial of the Chicago seven
which I just did a video
on a few weeks ago.
In that case, several defendants
were charged with traveling
to Chicago to start a riot.
Count one of the indictment
against them claim
that they conspired not only to travel in
and use the facilities
of interstate commerce
with the intent to insight, organize
and promote and encourage a riot
but also to participate
in and carry on a riot
to commit acts of violence
and further into the riot
and to aid and abet
persons in such activities.
But at the same time, this goes down
as one of the black marks
of federal prosecutions
because people largely perceive this trial
the Chicago seven as being a show trial
that was meant to punish the people
who participated in protests
and punish them for their
free exercise of speech.
And that takes us to a whole
raft of the less sexy crimes
but are ones that are
probably going to be complete slam dunks,
like the weapons charges
that are found in 40 U.S.C. section 5104,
which are oddly specifically tailored
to this particular situation
which says that you
cannot possess firearms
and other dangerous weapons in Congress.
And that you may not knowingly
with force and violence enter
or remain on the floor of
either house of Congress.
That really seems like
it applies to people
who entered the houses of Congress.
And then there is things
like assault on federal
officers in 18 U.S.C. 1114
that makes it a crime to kill
or attempt to kill any officer
or employee of the United States
or illegally possessing
a dangerous firearm
on any federal facility in 18 U.S.C. 930.
And then of course it
should surprise no one
that there's a whole bunch of laws
that prevent the destruction
of federal property.
And then of course there is perhaps
the most on the nose law in all of this is
18 U.S.C. 351 congressional cabinet
and Supreme court assassination,
kidnapping and assault
which it should surprise
no one makes it a crime
to assassinate, kidnap or
assault members of Congress,
the cabinet or the Supreme court.
It's also illegal to
attempt to do these things.
So even if you entered
Congress with the intent
to hurt a member of Congress,
you looked around and you
couldn't find a member of Congress
you're still probably guilty
of the attempt to do it.
So as you can imagine, that's
real bad news for the guy
that brought flex cuff
zip ties in to Congress
even though he actually
wasn't able to hold
any particular member of Congress hostage.
And then finally the
last category of crimes
that are likely under these circumstances,
depending on how aggressive
federal prosecutors want to be
are the whole swath of
antiterrorism laws that exist.
It's entirely possible that
federal prosecutors will look
at this as a terrorist incident.
This was a whole bunch
of people using force
and firearms and explosives
and trying to undermine the government
and achieve their political ends
in an anti-democratic way
in direct contravention
of the actual functioning US democracy.
It's entirely possible.
This qualifies as terrorism.
And I would not be surprised,
if federal prosecutors took that tack,
but the bottom line is that
this is all incredibly serious
and these people can be charged
with any number of these crimes.
And if they are indicted,
then they'll need to call
a really good lawyer.
And the best way to make that
call is with ting mobile.
I personally switched to Ting mobile why?
Well, because of this,
yes, that is a real bill
that I actually got.
But Ting mobile has three brand new plans
that make sure that that never happens.
You can get talk in texts
for only $10 a month.
Data plans starting at $15 a month,
and unlimited for everything
for $45 per month.
And switching plans actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any
phone at this point.
And the service is great
too because ting partners
with several massive networks in the US
very possibly the exact same carrier
that you're using right
now but at a huge discount.
Now contractually I can't tell
you which ones in particular,
because I always respect contracts,
but if you've ever gotten a bill like mine
your service probably won't change.
So whether you use two gigabytes
or 20 gigabytes a month
there's a perfect ting plan for you.
In the past I've been on the phone
with my cell phone carrier
for hours and hours
for even minor things.
But with ting, you can call them up
and a human will pick up right away.
Or if that's not your thing,
you can message them on internet,
even talk to them through discord.
And of course, if you're
around wifi all the time
like you're working from home,
then you have the flexibility
to save even more money
because ting flex plan
gives you the option
to just pay for what you use.
It's a smarter, cheaper
version of the same plan
that they've always had.
Now they just have the option
of unlimited versions as well.
So if you want unlimited
data, absolutely go crazy.
So if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com
or click on the link in the description,
you can use your last bill
to compare just how much you would save.
And legal Eagles will also
get a $25 service credit
that could cover months of service.
So just click on the
link in the description
and give it a try.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis,
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews,
where I talk about all the crazy stuff
that has happened in
the Trump administration
and out of the executive branch.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.